that'll take some nervousness away
because you got to deal with the guy in
front of you immediately yeah I mean you
made a great point I mean when you're
playing at Rupp Arena in front of 23,000
people oh my goodness Oh had a chance
for a three-point play you think a guy
like Jimmer Fredette grant has a chance
to make that Warriors team talked about
Jeff Ledbetter he's being able to see
him for a few years and so he
understands he broke a few things on
this one ankles one prior than other
whoops that's true for some excitement
they just got it off the fast-break by
Barnett getting way up in there better
that this season and again as I look
around this place is
[Applause]
a moment ago it's just a great pass it
starts with makrooh and then the finish
oh my oh my with ten now - Kay Kutta
thority five seconds brown Frank camp
Brandt camp doesn't get it off in time
and so Norville pal
they definitely practice dead we'll see
this dump your shake quartz vision just
throws it up there body slam yeah it
looked like something they worked on for
sure they're big nothing but attacking
the rim and it's Duncan season right now
for them way back here snap to the
screen man they're attacking their Tech
in the river that's it it's just dunk
mentality I love it I love ska leave it
ass beat that was a dangerous rebound
Evans of topology take a look good
smiling each go it up it was a little
behind though it started with one hand
finished it yeah that's real athletic
yeah how much a tie for one he's been in
the league for so long I don't again I
mean he's been in the league for so long
and just being able to experience things
yeah
the shot clock magic matching this
birthday to the NBA Robinson this play
was nice right here on the putback good
lord
he went over his own guy yeah
oversized 22 your guys arnelle Stokes
two three two threes ended in a spot up
to a turnaround jumper take a look at
the high-flying pucks getting went back
into it several run the within for 648
bird boarder cow our hard-working
physical position lists versus head
incapacitating compani wise there's 1000
run right now for the Clippers as
they've built their lead from 37 15
and I was going kay talk with the finish
watch how hard K [ __ ] crows creates a
lane give it to where no one else can
get it really good job late help right
here you got it
meet that world and the benefit for the
player is you get paid NBA wage over
that stretch of 45 days as the Clippers
light it up as Man 2 cap and le that
time on the Aleut Siteman here on that
man no look at one hand flush finished
have a plum and Robin Hoods you really
improves right his last couple of years
as a 3-point shooter but neither dishes
dogs by the Clippers that one courtesy
of Nigel Hayes whose baseline Romantics
is the free throw put a rebound for
Charlotte by miles bridges here's
bridges Simon has made a business
decision
more than likely with the right one so
this miles get attendant use it back
there now probably knows a little Emma
Sh
[Applause]
at eight was bumped here as well yeah by
the Gracie see right now they're
committed to having basketball programs
on the break Mulder Oh reverse Jam for
Michael Mulder that moves on penetration
but you know what he could also take it
upstairs so we got the spider camp gonna
do no Mulder
a little French pastry right bad
[Applause]
make this strong Martin came off slick
rocket has to mate matin no doubt of it
almost for those who are just now
joining us to easy you can't have a
player look at this I mean come on
rebound in the throwdown I know you had
a go to in your bag somewhere there's a
co2 slam again
well mr. Clark Nick and roll he has been
at this room consistently showing off a
vertical that's special hello
come on say green looked like he wanted
Elmore to bring it up eventually get
some anyway there and that's why he's
just allowing them to sleep little
summer chemistry at their own you go
there and then do that perfect pass and
under four minutes ago kappa leaders
need to make something happen on both
ends here waters two waves into the
reverse who said that young man was a
heck of an
[Music]
the reverse from Williams for some early
in the games prior the Boston Celtics
had Carol Lawson
upon's asses definitely that was the
show stop punished by the Bulls here's
the replay as Mychal Mulder steps over
outside the line so he's in legal
guarding position it's looked like a kid
that played in college and give to the
NBA how about a reverse lob Hayes dunked
so far this time he does it with a quick
mask you have to me basket how do you
let him get behind you that's another
good question cuz we saw him earlier go
baseline our Jefferson off you don't
want to get you don't necessarily have
to get boy you just can't let your man
here this is pretty good here watch
you've seen how many times we see
draymond Green do that right he just
lobs it up really nice pass by Hiro Hiro
is a very good help anybody seriously
consider drafting him it's never is good
in Suzy the dude he's dunking on a seven
feet any consciousness in terms of the
hesitation move beautifully by race
balding what a play but you see the
alley-oop coming here no weak side help
Garrett able to get down in lane for the
course Lanier is number retired by the
Bucks
dead poster look at Robinson going to
the top of the square to go throw that
one down
[Applause]
[Music]
so that we're coming hard left
balancing key in there too late for the
first of all poster they gotta be your
scout team quarterback they got a play
when necessary oh okay I mean when you
talk about toughness when you talk about
hard-nosed and you talk about deep in
that was Jack McClure
he's getting ready to make the next step
now what's the next Lee what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with wheat
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content